cette semaine aussi les sept deux très
beaux films issus de la compétition
d'ailleurs pas que de la compétition
cannoise ce très beau 72e festival de
cannes au festival réputé très dense et
très riche effectivement donc le premier
c'est sybille qui est un thriller
français de justin triais avec virginie
efira qui est en train de devenir une
star qui est déjà une star et adèle
exarque copello ce qui a été découverte
dans les films notamment de kechiche a
annoncé le bas a raconté l'histoire
c'est assez intense assez bouleversant
si l'histoire 10e puis une scie qui va
devenir romancière et qui rencontrent
crise qui va s'approprier son histoire
c'est assez vertigineux et c'est à
découvrir donc on sale au ciné cette
semaine le film est sorti la semaine
dernière est le deuxième film c'est le
jeune ahmed alors le jeune ahmed prix du
scénario pour les frères dardenne à
cannes
encore une fois un très très beau film
très prenant très bouleversant ça
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune garçon qui
s'appelle ahmed qui a 13 ans et qui est
tiraillé on va dire entre les lé désir
de pureté de son hymne alger parce qu'il
est très religieux et la dirige donc à
découvrir dans nos salles cette semaine
aussi 17
[Musique]